peut commencer en italie car goldman est
mort aujourd'hui à paris abattu en
pleine rue par des inconnus
car goldman mi-temps l'extrême gauche un
marginal et un révolté mais aussi un
malfaiteur fin d'année pour plusieurs
hold up défrayé les chroniques
judiciaires lors de deux procès en
assises où il était accusé des meurtres
de deux pharmaciennes du boulevard
richard lenoir à paris il ya dix ans
coleman était sorti de prison il ya
trois ans il avait écrit deux livres
titulaire de plusieurs diplômes
universitaires il collaborait depuis
dans diverses rues c'est près de son
domicile vers 12h30 que c'est
d'agresseurs l'attendait
pierre goldman habitait non loin de
cette rue dans le xiiie arrondissement
vers 12h30
il remonte ce trottoir le long de
l'hôpital de la croix rouge sur la place
des peupliers à l'heure du repas les
passants se croisent vite et font à
peine attention aux trois hommes qui
courent et tire plusieurs bases sur
pierre bohm celui ci s'effondre tué sur
le coup
j'ai vu trois gars y en un qui avait un
grand revolver et le jaune à peu près
une vingtaine d'années les coureurs y
fourrer oui j'ai entendu trois coups de
feu
pas moi je continuais toujours de
descendre de la colonie et les mecs qui
sort qui parce qu'après je me suis
arrêté
le mec qui sort sortie de l'autre côté
d'eux
la croix vous il ya une voiture rouge
qui les attendait avec quelqu'un à
l'intérieur des cakes avec un gars
peuvent trentaine d'années goldman est
mort on emporte son corps dans un
fourgon de police
l'homme était né de parents israélite
militant communiste il y à 35 ans
étudiant il s'engageait dans les luttes
syndicales et politiques mais des sujets
choisis c'est après mai 1968 d'être un
gangster
ce fut selon ses mots un parti calme et
lucide il y a dix ans après plusieurs
hold up il est arrêté et accusé des
meurtres de deux pharmaciennes du
boulevard richard lenoir il clamera
toujours son innocence dans cette
affaire mais il faudra un deuxième
procès en assises pour que des jurés lui
donnent raison
en prison il écrit un livre très
remarqué souvenirs obscurs d'un juif
polonais né en france
très sensibles à ça judaïcité cas
goldman était éloigné des milieux
d'extrême gauche
il était libre depuis trois ans quelques
minutes après avant même que soit connu
l'identité de la victime l'attentât est
revendiqué par un groupe baptisé honneur
de la police un groupe qui revendique a
déjà un attentat au mois de mai dernier
contre le véhicule d'un responsable de
la cgt les enquêteurs de la brigade
criminelle n'exclut cependant pas un
règlement de comptes
dans un communiqué le syndicat général
de la police ne peut croire que cet acte
odieux et pu être commis par des
policiers et ce syndicat demande que
tout soit mis en oeuvre pour découvrir
rapidement les assassins et le démon le
défenseur de goldman maître kiejman
lui-même ne croit pas à une pareille
hypothèse je pense que nous l'entendrons
dans notre dernier journal à 23h30
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui à
maisons laffitte